[Musik]
der reporter droge weg zum elften mal
laden die klinik für mehr kontrollierte
entzug
[Musik]
am jeder kämpft mit ihrer fitness sucht
und das städtische klinik gegangen
eine andere bezug
das ist eine betreute spielsüchtig und
hätte schwerer rückfall hinter sich
wunderbar das gehalt von der sozialhilfe
spielten sie bei weihnachten und alles
ohne geld
mit er weiß was simon verhalten tue und
offene rechnungen beglichen
[Musik]
the only one trick versucht ins leben
dreht dort trifft die heime noch meine
monat in der klinik alltag aussieht es
acht heimische damit verschiedene
drogenproblem
[Musik]
im moment ist prien und depressionen
das ist schön
und stellt für die wohnung
[Musik]
jetzt wird rät unbedingt wieder schaffen
ja ja sogar
ich denke das ist meinte das kleine
tierschau wenn man das home-office
google.com eigentlich sehr gut
ausgezeichnet
also auch hier also ins korn
ich habe mir da so ganz viel merkt hat
und ab krank gemacht
ja das mit einer attacke ist immer nur
als thema mehr das ist sehr viel besser
geworden aber es ist nach wie vor das
thema um für mich sehr belastendes thema
ohne behalten ist ein großes plus auf
den körper und auf meine psyche hat und
es begünstigt hat das ganze mit dem
training
das macht viele meinen otz das
üblicherweise spiel
wo halt einfach nur ein prozent hat bis
vor kurzem agieren finden es sucht und
renate stöhr klinik sie eine gute
einigung eine angst hatte
[Musik]
treffer mit ihrer gruppe sind nackte
regelmäßige therapie sprache führt jeder
wichtig die nächtliche attacke sehr
unkontrolliert vor einfach nicht im
griff
also es ist nicht immer das passiert
vielleicht so eine schöne woche
aber das ist für mich immer noch zu
wenig ich möchte das los weiter und ich
weiß nicht wie ich hab das ist nicht
einfach wurde da musst du machen
ja ich hätte das anders machen oder aus
leeds an dem buch mx nach dem essen
schützen sich also schon immer so dass
ich jetzt irgendwie rennt los ist
das ist nett es ist ja nicht so dass ich
jetzt unmenge ist dass das habe ich eine
super show ja das ist so sagt es so
lange gemacht aber ich bin die handlung
von krieg tun
ja ich bin so stolz auf dich wenn du
machst es so gut ich gewiss früher sich
mit masse vor sie sich wirklich
ausschaut hat damit schlimm
und das sehe ich jetzt nehme ich sehe
dass sie brachten hat also brach
schlankere weiß ich nicht ob sie genug
ist das
weiß ich nicht und ich gemacht
[Musik]
samir dort trainiert wieder häufig
mehrmals am tag immer nur definiert sie
sich fest darüber wie sie erzählt über
ihre fit körper
[Musik]
das forum hat er recht
wenn die maschinen geben aber ich habe
einfach gemerkt dass das ist somit also
dass ich nicht also das haben ja vorher
schon gesagt ich will es nicht einfach
in einen anderen bezug dafür über grund
ich muss es nicht also im training fühle
ich mich sicher im training weiß ich was
ich kann und was ich kann
samira gibt regelmäßige fitness struktur
immer neue job und lebt von der
krankenversicherung
da ich in dem man nicht weiß wie sie
begonnen dass ich für mich als er in usa
also falsch - haltbarer zustand will ich
einfach nicht vorwärts machen
ich will ja wissen halt mal wieder ein
lichtblick an der uni und im moment
nicht und das ist das was wir jetzt eine
familie ist klar die hoch bauzeichnerin
trug ihre blue spotted verschaffen
[Musik]
sie habe dort ein metallbaufirma berufe
temporale bier zu bruch diese kassette
bereich high performance zweite chance
sich richtig glauben
das ist
das mal probieren erklärte metallbauer
aus dass hätte schon lange im geschäft
ist extrem schräg sind sobald sie wieder
aufnehmen
aber es kommt der medizin
[Musik]
derzeit ist spielsüchtig und leidet
unter depressionen
am herrn die zocker online casinos oder
spielt sportwetter sucht er den einsam
gemacht egal sorge der job und klar
spielt weiter
faszination vor den spielen was ich
staus wasser faszinieren
ach so klar zu machen falls die
situation ist ernst machen die letzte
jahr über 130 franken verspielt
[Musik]
internetcafes und es ist ganze gehalt
von der sozialhilfe rund 800 franken
verspielt
aber raffte sich ruf
herrgott nach buchen wieder eine
therapie
[Musik]
da spielt dritte grund liegt 800 über
das alles spielt das problem ich habe
meine frau wirklich wieso man konnte bis
800 + aber man würde also jetzt haben
sie das geld für dezember irgendwann
sehen sie bei wein und alles ohne
geldsorgen
das große problem von jb in der heimat
fuß dazu geführt hat also sie haben das
geld gesehen dass es wenig ist sie in
eine menge zu zahlen rechnungen und dann
ist sage mir was hat ob die sicherung
durchgebrannt und das in sich zocken
gegangen
erst ist man tritt wirklich so wurde
nächsten tag zu kommen wo hat man gar
nicht wo und was ist wenn sie gut
verstehen was machen sie natürlich was
nicht so ganz ideal ist wenn es in
dieser käferfreunde gruppe gehen und
dann
relativ ziehen können
oakley ich mir noch zeit hat man sich
drauf freuen
[Musik]
bezieht am weihnachtsmarkt essensangebot
stellt samira oft proben besten freundin
unterwegs
[Musik]
über kino ganz genau was sie ist und was
nicht
natürlich ist der hintergedanke schon
immer das ist jetzt nicht zum beispiel
ja wohl einfach sagt mühe ist bleich und
tolle grad an das papier ist und denken
wir noch vor der klinik ist mir aber
dass sauber verantwortlich für sich und
ihre richtig selber überlegt was ist das
jetzt weil irgendwann ist es wenn ich
mir bis süd
[Musik]
nach einer woche ist der retro wieder
auf jobsuche
es funktioniert mit dem parkett wurden
ettlingen muss sich fünf sechs kilo
zweiter arbeit ein anderer job finden
[Musik]
das ist aber nicht die einzige option
tretow entscheidet sich für saab arbeite
mit dieser stiftung baden muss damit
weiterhin je nach linie schritt für
nachhaltig und es ist struktur
ja sie müssen wenn sie nicht
es ist wirklich strukturiert und sie
herr gesellschaft mir also sie sind für
ihr rhetorisches zwar straff aber eine
beschäftigung
[Musik]
einige buche gott redet frei viele
blüten die letzte schwierige jahr holte
[Musik]
bebra
und sind sie häufiger die glaube dass
gott mit punkt und kommt auf den
vorschlag von politik sein können aber
fachlich songs alle bäume
manche finden und somit die evivo muss
er vorderhand und die ordnung und
gemeinschaft noch viele zieht es mit
sammeln
[Musik]
im retro ganz langsam bergauf
dort verbringt wieder mehr zeit mit
freunden harper's island andere am
liebsten und rohstoffwirtschaft aber
noch keine einzige bewerbung schrieb sie
fahrlässig war sie zum abschluss trifft
aber mit dem kunden die schon ist sie
jahren spielsüchtig teil hoch ab und zu
in könnte offen über ihre probleme reden
gemeinsam die beides ich glaube sie ist
ihres fahrstils dazu je nach zeit zur
gewöhnt sie für einen moment vergessen
zum beispiel vor ladiges kleines
flugzeug nichts
aber dann war die stimme so lang jetzt
dakar resigniert ein paar kleine blüten-
oder erhält geklärt so wussten diese
aber ich auch ist problem oder wenn man
mitglied habe ich auch glücklicher
problem hat dann wird man nicht gesund
so viel drin
es ist niemand ob man selber schuld
samira wird kapitel sucht er im leben
abschließen und das ohne auf ihren
körper
[Musik]
indianische kriegerin sie wenn du mal
bei uns und für mich selbst gerade
einfach aufgrund verteile ganz
richtige sitzung das jetzt machen so
quasi als neue erfahrungen und krampf
für ihn auf das am morgen für sie selber
stand für jede wo sie sich darauf
befindet aber große ganze merke ich dass
ich auf dem richtigen weg ist sozusagen
grund langsam bin gespannt und bereitet
so was wo wer das versucht mit bekannt
verdienen rampe wird egal warum
[Musik]
derzeit hat glück
dies sei damit meinen vorschuss vom
sozialamt zahlt ihre alte heimat der
türkei hätten nur offene rechnungen die
worte begleichen
das gelte für hätte man eine schnee
ziehen die familie
die türkei juni um geld gespielt der
kreis und zum feld ins ziel
[Musik]
weil ernst es so zu problemen denn ob
direkt oder alkohol und störe sie
türgriff von swiss müsse abgab
die kursmuster zahlen zu spät tun haben
sagt monaten immer toben oder weisen mit
[Musik]
türkei nord wurde zeugt 17 kindheit
immer wieder fehler gemacht
das neulich detroit nicht immer noch so
aber die schweiz tvs müssen erst
türkisch zu kohle
[Musik]
aber jetzt geht's erst zum zahnarzt hat
also dringend nötig
der zahnarzt der türkei viel günstiger
letztlich geht die ganze hand dass die
schweiz nach zwei wochen sind
entscheidend sind die schlechtem zustand
in spanien und vielleicht noch 10
ersetzt werden
jetzt braucht aber zeit eine krone und
das zahnimplantat dance to joy wieder
gurken
[Musik]
tamedia ich mir eine freundin der flüsse
berge
[Musik]
die freundinnen julia beobachtet dass es
orte samira viel besser gott ich bin der
bands vor und man merkt dass sie sich
wohl fühlt im körper und seele strahlt
sie haltlos
diese neue tattoo du bist weg sieht war
ich mir große rainer kohl wurde der liga
ist klar wenn ich es gemacht
zum sandwich auch zum sport zu - karl
stewart und retreats letzte woche hat
sie ihre erste vorstellungsgespräch als
fitness-coach sport süchtig und asstel
regionales und dann noch die richtigen
eigenschaften des falschen aber ich habe
mich haben wirklich zählt viel gedanken
über das gemacht und die ohren also das
eigentliche gefangen haben nicht dass
ich das die vision dass auch eine zu
machen und um setzen wir ganz genau was
er lässt sie weisen in ihren schweiß
auch nicht gerade die risiken ich jetzt
durchgemacht haben und glaubt dass das
so sei negativ und die scharte sich
tierhaltung froh sind dass ich das kann
bieten und dass er sich jetzt lernwillig
land vielleicht flog sie hat sich vor
vier jahren bekam mit dass auch er
selbst hätte haye mega cool was du
machst aber vorsicht
[Musik]
also ich wünsche mir einfach nach wie
vor vielleicht noch mal ein stück mehr
mit mir selber also doch lee ja mal
eigentlich ist das schon so
detroit stattfindet letzte motiv ist
glasklar kabarett polizei ihn verwischt
und eine türkisch fonds müssen abgaben
ja wir nächste saison gehen
[Musik]
ja da bin ich nach modernes sofa kann ja
mit dem wo der abschlüsse und sie die
borussia inzwischen zurück das hatte mit
vier große electric für ihn mit einer
kritik über hunderte fans zurück
[Musik]
ein vorsatz oder dem mieter aus wie sie
der schweiz wozu kohlenberg musste sucht
vor online guide spiel
er sucht wo ihm fehlt er weiß das muster
bliebe ganz geschafft hätte es noch
nicht
[Musik]
teilweise tweets gedimmt dankbar dass
das was er bringt jetzt muss sich mit
kämpfen dass geschätzt
[Musik]
drei männer sind vergangen reto sie denn
hätte sie nie kurs abgearbeitet
bis jetzt hätten keine droge kommt
[Musik]
und er ist gestiegen
das sei der grund es geht über gestank
gar nicht
[Musik]
jetzt brauchten um eine feststellung es
im glück
dieses besten geben
[Musik]
klar also noch kein ponyhof mich sehr
dass die vergangen sind wir dann alles
wieder normal
das lager
[Musik]
vorgestellt werden